[Music]
do it man how you doing I'm good I'm
good are you cool thanks for making the
trip out here I really appreciate it
okay thanks for having me I'm excited
yeah it's been a long time in the making
I think we first got connected through
Noah Lang it's dry yeah right exactly in
2011 or 12 or something they're just
doing 13 yeah it's been a long time
right and you did like you did that you
climbed like I'm like a building in San
Francisco right yeah they took me on an
urban soloing to Uruk San Francisco
right that's pretty cool man yeah yeah
and then here was it's it's rare that a
sponsor takes you on a tour of soloing
in a city looks like this League or do
we have permits for anything and they
were like no it'll be fine yeah cool
have you done have you have you been
filmed climbing buildings before is that
the only time I had a little bit of
climb buildings but I actually haven't
climbed that many buildings but there
there was almost a big TV special where
I was gonna climb a taipei 101 and
taipei i think in the time was the fifth
fifth tallest building in the world and
so as part of that I did a bunch of
practice climbing on buildings so I've
done a bunch of stuff around Boulder in
Denver and right it's pretty fun but um
but now I've never climbed that many
buildings right it's it's I just
actually though if anybody ever hears
this I still really want to climb Taipei
where the the TV project fell apart
mm-hmm and so then the building doesn't
really want you to climb it without it
without there being a reason right so I
never had the opportunity to climb even
though I rehearsed it and I'm totally
ready so if anybody wants to all the
Prevention's don't listen I am ready to
con type in one at the drop of a hat and
has he done that no no a welcome stunt
so I'm a French guy at Lamoreaux bear
climbed it with ropes as part of the
inauguration in the building or
something like that some kind of event
but um but I ready to go climb at any
time no recently I up yeah by myself Wow
it's awesome it's an amazing building
it's really ornamental it's over hanging
on on sides it's really cool I would
imagine with with a project like that
the wind becomes a huge deal right
that's funny everybody thinks that but
um I don't know
I've never exert 'only no worse wind on
a building than there is on big cliffs
mm-hmm and certainly far less wind than
there are in the real mountains like in
Patagonia mm-hmm probably a little bit
more predictable right because the the
sort of geometry of the building is
you know what to expect yeah I actually
I don't know I would actually
hypothesize that a building like Taipei
101 would be less affected by the wind
in a way because it's on it dominates
Taipei it's so much bigger than the rest
of the city
so you're just way above everything else
huh whereas in somewhere like New York
City you might get buffeted of all kinds
of crazy we're coming on the course yeah
you're in corridors but if you're on
something that's three times taller and
everything else and it's like you're
just you know it's like being on the
mountain here whatever the weather is is
what you're getting right cool
so you just you just came from New York
dealing in the trip yeah so let's can we
talk about that yeah for sure for sure I
mean unbelievable right this was a
pretty cool trick that's pretty cool
maybe just describe it for people that
are listening who aren't familiar with
what you just accomplished what I mean I
know about compition well but it was
that it was the North Face expedition to
Antarctica so there were six of us who
were climbers on the team and then there
was a seventh filmmaker and and we
basically just went to this area in
Queen Maud land which is one of the the
sectors of Antarctica explored by the
Norwegians and so we went to this area
that's the Norwegian word for the the
Wolf's jaw it's like a basically
serrated teeth in the shape of the jaws
like a big u shape of mountains it looks
like a Wall Street yeah it's crazy
especially from the air it looks like
wolf der and enjoy from what I
understand it wasn't even discovered
until like the 90s no wasn't it wasn't
climbed until the nose
so the whole area had been mapped
through aerial photography and actually
randomly I think the Nazis that drop
little leaf lady things to claim it as
part of Germany in the 1930s or 40s but
um but yeah the peaks weren't actually
climbed until the 90s wow that's amazing
it's really difficult to get there I
mean I think like with a project like
that
it's the logistics have to be insane and
not just complicated and difficult but
also very expensive and so it sort of
requires a sponsor like the North Face
or the people that went to the first and
the 90s who were a Norwegian it was like
a Norwegian national pride it was like a
very big expedition writing our way so
it's you Conrad Anker yeah Jimmy Jimmy
Chan cedar and then Savannah Cummins and
Anitha
we're both also of nine years but I saw
some of the footage that they aired
during the CBS thing that you guys did
and I was like it's so epic to
see it but I'm like how are you like
here's one of the questions I have just
in general with all of these things that
you do like there's always somebody
filming whether it's Jimmy chin or
somebody else and and half the time
these are like like cedar there's a lot
of footage of him holding the camera
like how do you do what you're trying to
do and have to pay attention to like
documenting the thing I mean I mean
that's a big question but so one of the
really nice things about filming a cedar
is that the filming feels exactly like
it would with a friend like you're
desired doing your normal thing and
whenever you can you just pull the
camera out and like exactly how you
would shoot selfies of each other if you
were just basically I documented I shot
a lot of video on my iPhone so that
there would be material of cedar
climbing because he had a real camera I
mean still small that he kept in his
jacket but basically just film each
other we just have a good time right
anytime I'm taking my camera out to get
a panorama starting show my girlfriend
or something because I was taking photos
from every summit because we're like
we're in this crazy place it's a
once-in-a-lifetime trip like I want to
go home and show my family because it's
cool so every time you take your camera
you also just shoot a little while here
we are we're having this nice experience
right but I was to the cedar I mean his
style of filmmaking is to turn that into
a movie that's actually watchable and so
who's handling like the drone
photography so that was the seventh guy
that's got Pablo de Rana Hans um he's a
filmmaker from from California area but
he is the world's most interesting man
he's amazing he's uh he was on an
expedition with me in Angola and then I
sort of recommended him for this trip
and then cedar hired him as the
cameraman for this trip but um he he was
like a collegiate runner he's fit as
he's very very fit somewhere yeah my
love to curse on the show yeah he's uh
he's very fit you know i form in a mild
type of fit and then but also clients
about 13 which is like a very difficult
level of climbing and so we would all be
out doing our thing climbing mountains
and then you see Pablo like skiing by
with a 60 pound sled with a bunch of big
drones to go shoot when you're just like
Pablo is sleeping with all the batteries
in his sleeping bag like on his chest
basically so to keep the laptops from
freezing at night and then to keep all
the drone batteries and very camera
batteries so he was sleeping with all
the batteries and it sleep Meg and then
he'd wake up every three hours to move
the solar panels around his tent because
uh God you know because there's 24 hours
of sunlight yeah you still have to the
Sun still moving so yeah but um so yeah
basically Pablo never slept a full night
at this toilet
he's an amazing it was amazing wow it's
like a different level of fitness and
he's still motivated and kind he's just
like having a great time uh-huh
so so you guys all get to Cape Town
right and you got hung up for a little
while because of weather trying to get
you know find your way to Antarctica
right yeah so when we got to there'd
been a big storm and there'd been a
meter of fresh snow on an on a three
mile long runway I think it is of ice
because you're landing on a sheet of ice
so basically they have to clear this
enormous sheet of ice and that's to land
at the logistical base and then from
there we took a smaller plane to the
actual base camp on a in the glacier
like in the wolf's job because that felt
like really rickety old plane I read
something about like some ancient planet
oh that might have been on the first
expedition because Conrad had been there
before a long time ago I think when he
went without looks low I'm yeah exactly
huh I think our trip had our planes were
up to code as its it all felt safe so
you land on I or no maybe actually maybe
what you read about was on when we
landed at the logistic base the flight
from Cape Town to Antarctica we the
flight there was on this Russian cargo
jet so we were sitting on wooden benches
with exposed wiring all around and all
the cargos just held down by Nets and it
was pretty amazing that's probably a
fairly long flight right yes six hours
oh my god but um but somehow it's pretty
easy when you fly six hours across the
States you're like oh this is such a
long flight but when you're flying six
hours to Antarctica you're just like
kind of giddy and excited I mean you
know you're going right guy it was
pretty cool
so you land on ice and then how do you
get to like the Wolf's jaw so then we
took a twin otter like a little small
plane like a propeller plane and that
has skis on it and it can kind of land
wherever and so that just dropped us off
in the glacier right and so the idea is
you're gonna some of these six peaks and
do it in ten days yeah I don't know I
think CBS ran something about six peaks
but they're actually tons of peaks there
I climbed I climbed 14 different summits
that I counted while I was there some of
them were pretty insignificant but but a
bunch of them were really cool uh-huh
and yeah and there was no plan we just
showed up there expecting to climb as
much as we could right and so you just
set up like a base camp I mean I saw the
huge like yellow tubular done with it it
looked like you had to dig like you know
dig holes for that right yeah well the
cook tent is a big dome that sits but
then you dig in to make the kitchen
which is awesome because then you
make the counters whatever height you
want you make the seats whatever height
you know you tuck the cooler into the
counters it's all like built-in I mean
it's like sculpture it's pretty fun to
create your kitchen the way you want it
uh-huh how long's that take to like I
mean once you get there and then you
gotta like well I guess it's it's
daylight 24 hours yes daily hours and
when we landed we probably spent the
next five or six hours digging just like
setting up our tents digging holes like
digging the latrine things like that you
know setting up our situations so that
things are sheltered from the wind and
also like settled in enough that
nothing's gonna disappear right but I
mean in the grand scheme of things five
hours to set up a camp that you're gonna
live in for several weeks it's really
not that hard so how long were you down
there in total the whole expedition I
think was six weeks with flying to Cape
Town waiting in Cape Town so we we
waited five days in Cape Town and then
we waited maybe five days in the
logistics base novo this Russian nervous
and then so the time on the glacier
inter actual camp was only 17 days or
something right but who's supposed to be
closer to a month I think uh-huh but
then realistically we climbed I climbed
enough you know I have like this is
perfect and then they actually flew us
out slightly early just because the way
the weather was but um Connor and Jimmy
had finished their objective and cedar
Knight climbed everything we wanted to
do and right we were all just like it's
time to go home and Conrad had been
there before but for you guys you're
sort of it's unchartered territory like
you know one of the things I know that
you you're you're pretty meticulous
about is you know really mapping what
you're gonna do and all the preparation
that goes into these routes different
kind of climb yes that's for big free
solos and stuff I mean I love the
adventurous climbing where you just walk
out look at a mountain and choose what
looks like the easiest way and just have
an experience on and I mean I enjoy that
as well but um but certainly for the big
free soul is the type of climbing that I
may be more well known for that's more
about the planning in the preparation
mm-hmm but um but Antarctica was cool I
mean I I've never had an experience like
that yeah because it like it feels like
you're in space and you're climbing with
like ski boots and gloves on you know
the a different thing
I only climbed I think of everyone on
the team I was maybe the only person
that climb in ski boots a couple times
and that was just because the climbing
was relatively easy for me I want to
keep my feet warm I was just like I want
to be comfortable right but um for the
most part we would ski to the base and
then we would change into rock shoes and
I'm the rock and climbing shoes but
really big ones with big socks and
everything and then you'd kind of climb
barehanded if you had to but keep gloves
on if you could if it was easy enough
right
and then honestly the difficult part was
getting back down off everything because
there no established anchors nobody's
climbed anything before so there no
there's no way down right so once you
get to the top you then have to just use
the equipment that you have to create
anchors to slowly rappel back down and
on and how many of the the climbs were
you just inventing new routes versus
sort of tracking Wow there was one route
the last tree that we climbed which is
on I think the second tallest formation
in the region and we did the first free
ascent and the second is maybe second or
third ascent total of this Norwegian
route that they put up in the 90s and so
that one had a bunch of ropes left on it
and stuff like left over from from their
expedition because they'd kind of like
escaped in the storm and left some ropes
on it but for us we're like Oh signs of
human passage this is so nice
you know because after a couple weeks of
just doing everything totally virgin you
know it was nice to see some some signs
of passage and know that you're on the
right track and that someone else has
done it what was the hardest part of the
whole thing for me the hard part was
constantly thinking you're gonna die not
to say yeah yeah it's funny because it's
been a month and a little over a month
since I got home and that sort of fear
is starting to fade and you just look
back and like Oh such a good trip we had
this great time but every day like while
I was there each day was like pretty
stressful because we were making so many
little decisions that you think is the
right decision it's probably the right
call but like if you just fell and died
one you know there were a lot of times
where if cedar and I just wound up dead
at the base of the wall people would
just be like well that's what happens
when you're rappelling in big big
mountains like that that nobody's ever
been on like stuff happens right I don't
know well this conversation around fear
and death I mean this is this comes up I
mean it's impossible for anybody to have
a conversation with you without that I
mean you get annoyed you know no I'm
tired I'm like talking about it no I
think people which I think people should
think about that stuff more you know
when when does last time the average
person thought about the mortality and
really made choices that could lead to
death I mean my other than lifestyle
versus micro eating a Twinkie
are so far removed that you don't get
that immediate like sense of dread yeah
they're like oh my god I'm so afraid if
I eat this I'm gonna die in four years
some heart disease you know it's like a
different right no well I think that
that most of us live our lives in a
waking dream and we expend a tremendous
amount of energy trying to pretend we're
not going to die or denying that I think
that's such a situation healthier
perspective on him because you're so
connected with that reality actually you
said I was just in New York for the CBS
Morning Show thing and a Gayle Gayle
King I guess like big TV i I've never
met her obviously but she came out she
was one of the host of this morning show
and she was like oh you guys survived
this experience like didn't you think
you're gonna die and I was like whoa I
mean we're all gonna die like I mean
you're gonna die you know we're each
gonna die it doesn't necessarily matter
and who's like oh the conversation was
really dark that was it was just funny I
was like oh no and last time Gayle is
really thinking about her mortality you
don't whom the last time Gayle is like I
could die right now
mm-hm you know and I was like ha I guess
people I mean particularly if you're
living in a city like that you just
don't think about like death that much
well I think our culture is set up to to
encourage us to not think about it as
well you know we're sort of you think
we're yeah I think word of it we're
encouraged to seek security and you know
lead these safe lives and protect
ourselves and when the subject of death
comes up it's uncommon makes people that
makes you uncomfortable we don't know I
don't see why because it's one of those
things that shouldn't be uncomfortable
because we're all gonna die you know
it's like going to the bathroom or
something it's like we all go to the
bathroom punched on today it's like it's
part of being an animal like this is but
we try to remove it kind of dog
consciousness and awareness like I've
only seen one dead person in my entire
life when Julie's father passed away we
happen to be there but beyond that I've
never I'm like everybody dies but I've
never seen a dead person why is that
like it made me think about that in a
way that I hadn't before and I think
it's because it's just it's not part of
polite culture right like we're not
we're not comfortable talking about it
we want to remove it from our awareness
as soon as it happens like let's get it
out of our consciousness or you think
the line of sight I don't know I don't
totally feel that way but I mean I guess
yeah I might prefer yeah
it might be true
for society in general but so I mean if
we're if we're going dark I mean pretty
heavy so before the Antarctic trip it's
been a really grim year for rock
climbing there like a lot of big
accidents and fatalities and just
terrible things have happened in
climbing this year has been it's been
pretty hard like several friends and I
don't know it's just been rough but so
my girlfriend was pretty unexcited about
me going to Antarctica just because it's
you know fundamentally a dangerous trip
no I mean it's just you mean you're out
there you know like there is risk
involved for sure because you're all
pine climbing in the middle of nowhere
and so like there is definitely risk and
she was like a little worried and been a
hard year and then the day before I was
gonna leave we were support climbing in
Red Rock and like there's this terrible
accident this guy died like right next
to us and and actually it was my first
time in climbing seeing seeing a
fatality like that I mean I've been
around a lot of accidents and I've
certainly I hadn't known a lot of people
that have had things happen like that
but I've never just like seen somebody
you know we came around the corner and
there were people doing CPR on this on
this poor guy but I mean but he looked
dead and yeah well I think I think he
was basically just dead from the
beginning but they did CPR on him for
half an hour until paramedics got there
and and the the fireman was like this
guy's dead and then I stopped right so
how do you process that like did that
make you think about things differently
I mean you're you're you've lost a lot
of friends yeah yeah though I mean you
always justify in different ways and and
the thing is I mean I guess for me I
think I'm pretty
you know I've sort of accepted a certain
level of risk and I kind of know there's
certain danger and so when you see
things see accidents happen you're like
yeah I mean I know that there's a degree
of risk involved the nuts I mean like
that is the degree of risk yeah you said
one time I saw somewhere you said high
consequence is not the same as grave
danger mm-hmm yeah I mean was so I often
differentiate between risk and
consequence because people are like oh
what you're doing is super risky and I'm
always like oh what I'm doing is super
high consequence meaning that if if
something happened I would for sure to
die talking about free soloing walls but
it's not necessarily risky because the
risk is the likelihood of me actually
falling off and that you know you can't
really determine that from seeing a
picture or seeing a video clip or
something because you know that's
something the only I
how solid I am on the wall like how
likely I am to fall off of it mm-hmm but
no I think it's similar to you know when
you see someone like Laird Hamilton
you know surfing a gigantic wave and
you're like how to meet that well this
guy's flirting with death and yeah what
people don't realize or perhaps under
appreciate is the lifetime of work that
went to building up to that I mean he
can hold this breath for four minutes
I'm sure he could be pinned down and he
can survive a lot that if I fell off a
wave like that I would for sure diet
I don't even swim that well I can't like
those micro adjustments right and but he
also probably appreciates the difference
in the consequences because falling off
a wave like that isn't guaranteed death
I mean big wave surfers are rarely on a
wave that you're going to die I mean
people wreck all the time and they do
occasionally die but it's not like
Garren's certainty yeah yeah I mean they
often get pulled out or swim out or you
know whatever like they manage I don't
know the degree of consequence is
different but the risk is probably much
higher because they probably fall off
quite a bit more right it's just more
about it's more about the relationship
between the understanding of our
appreciation of the certainty of death
visa vie you know the fear like the fear
impulse and from what I understand like
you've just developed an ability to have
a presence of mind and a mindfulness to
manage that in a way that is unique I
don't know about how you had like the
MRI in your brain and the other guy was
like your amygdala just doesn't doesn't
fire no no that was the guy before that
all right if you read the article there
is um there was a quote from a guy I've
been like ah but his amygdala doesn't
work but then when we did the whole the
brain scan the functional MRI and
everything they found that I do happen
to make blood and well of course you
have it does it yeah acting Nazi well I
was sort of like Jenner
yeah well it's always a little movement
doing some takes a look under the hood
you like I hope it's all in there uh-huh
but um but no all the parts were there
and the amygdala was functioning it just
wasn't firing during this certain test
but I'm showing you like images like
graphic images yeah there's your graphic
images and I was like well
that trigger free response was just a
picture who cares but had they put you
know poisonous snakes into the freaking
machine with me I'm sure I'm sure I
would have been all lit up right right
right no it was just this level it was
was was different different from like a
control group
yeah response right yeah and and I think
one of the notable things in the article
was that I mean this is this isn't real
science this is like an anecdotal it was
like me versus one other climber who was
the control he was another I think a PhD
student or something that worked in that
lab who also rockland so since we were
roughly the same size and age and
demographic that just compared us and he
also felt like the pictures weren't very
stimulating because I mean it's just
random pictures his brain still lit up
in the way that you would expect whereas
mine didn't but the thing is the
interpretation can either be that
through you know 10 years of systematic
practice I've sort of dampened my
response or I'm just slightly
handicapped in some way and that's why
I've gotten good at free sewing's
because my brain is never lit up like
that but so you know I personally
because I I know how much I've grown
over time in my climbing and so I see it
more as a practice thing because I know
that I couldn't have done the things
that I do now ten years ago because I
just hadn't hadn't learned how yeah you
know hadn't produced but I'm sure other
people can interpret it and whatever
whatever I though yeah I mean it seems
to me that it's a it's the result of
like an intention and an in a sort of
diligent focus on honing that over the
years because from what I I mean my
perspective and could tell me if I'm
wrong but it seems like you're what
distinguishes you isn't necessarily your
physical capabilities it's your ability
to like be present and manage you know
the mental chatter so that you can be
completely in the moment of what you're
doing and keep them keep that like you
know that fear response or whatever it
is at bay so that you can be extremely
focused over like an extended period of
time possibly yeah I mean it's hard to
know because I don't know what goes on
in other people's minds so you know I'm
like as far as I'm concerned everybody
thinks the same way I do I'm like aw
it's totally normal it's totally natural
but then but this is all you've ever
done and known yeah well exactly and
something like well maybe this is a
little unusual
[Music]
I know you have this like aw shucks kind
of you know reaction to all of this you
know because it seems totally natural
right because it's yes you are the
fundamental yeah exactly
mm-hmm so you wouldn't I wouldn't know
differently yeah but though I I think as
I get older I appreciate more and more
that it's maybe a little bit different
just because um I came out my girlfriend
and like getting to know other people
well you know they have like sort of
normal anxieties and they like have you
know they tweak about things more and
they stress things more and I'm just
like I just don't like ever
you're like full stop really I mean not
to say that I don't worry about some
stuff or like have stress in my life a
little bit but I just like do not I
don't know very little you know their
nature and nurture thing yeah oh my god
oh no no no but taking it back to the
beginning you know when you when you
first when you start climbing like when
you were like 11 or 12 yeah yeah and and
and it wasn't like initially out of the
gate like oh this guy is not a phenom no
and that's the thing is I've never been
physically gifted at all I mean after 20
years of of regimented practice and
training I'm still not as good as a lot
of people that you know there are a lot
of people with physical gifts and
climbing and I'll just never be as as
strong a climbers as they are but I mean
climbing is a big sport and people sort
of go in their own directions and so if
I was to ask Conrad or Jimmy or any of
these other guys like what what makes
you different or unique or or special or
able to do the things that you've been
able to do that no one else has been
able to do like what would they say I
don't know actually it's interesting you
mention them because in a way they both
sort of represent a generation before me
like slightly more old-school adventury
you know like big mountain type
experience and so actually so compared
to their generation sort of like the big
wall type dudes I am much more
physically gifted as a climber but then
compared to my contemporaries and people
of you know coming up in the new
generation of climbing I'm very very
weak by comparison with them you know
like standards have been steadily
changing and so compared to somebody
like Conrad I'm like a much better
technical climber and that's because I
grew up climbing and climbing gym and
you know starting at the age of 11 or 12
I was practicing technique and working
on my footwork and you know I got
stronger fingers whereas Conrad wasn't
climbing till he was in the dole and he
was climbing out door
he was never it's a different kind of
yeah it's very different and you kind of
came up at this perfect time yeah I
really became a thing that you could
actually do as a living I mean if you
would that's ten years earlier it might
have been a different yeah for sure and
not not just that um that being able to
be a professional climber sort of became
an option for me but also I grew up with
gyms I'm like I'm the first generation
of gym climbers and now kids growing up
today have much better gyms yeah and
they're climbing at a much higher level
I mean much better facilities much more
talent and that you're just you're
seeing a different level and the
awareness is so mainstream now they can
point you like yourselves and say
there's a path towards you know being in
that situation we're still a little bit
early like when you decided you were
gonna do this it wasn't like oh I can do
this for a living why didn't I just
nomadic exactly I didn't even decide I
just you know I was like oh I'm just
going to climbing all the time and
eventually sort of morphed into making a
living from it but um it's interesting
at events now having kids come up and
say I want to be a professional climber
and I'm like ha you know like that was
never really I gotta do you know but I
mean it's cool you know yeah I mean it
was it seems interesting the way that it
kind of developed for you because you
did you went to Berkeley right and over
here right you know for a year I'm gonna
be an engineer and you ended up dropping
out but that was sort of around it like
your father passed away passed away in
your life actually both my grandfather's
dad died in the previous year too and
and when you look back on that what is
the do you feel like that was part did
that give you a perspective on how you
wanted to live your life that compelled
you and I'm looking back on it it
probably it definitely added a sense of
urgency to things a little bit or a
certain um a good reminder that life is
finite and that you know you should do
the things that you want to do mm-hmm
but um it's funny though because you
know looking back on it now 10 years out
of you're like oh I dropped out of
school to become a climber but when when
it was happening I was taking a semester
off so I could go climbing and then I
took another semester off and then I
took the next 20 semesters off or
whatever well it's not like I dropped
out I just like didn't ever go back
right but you you had this thing that
you loved and you wanted to express that
in your life and you wanted that to be a
bigger part of who you
yes something that I cared about much
more than the occasional wood it may
have just clamp that down and said yeah
but I got to get through college I got
it you know the social pressures the
familial pressures like and then slowly
over time that you know that that
climbing instinct just turns into
weekend expeditions and then yeah a
month and then you're 45 years old and
you're like what the [ __ ] happened yeah
I mean I'm just kind of lucky that it
worked out that way in some ways I mean
I definitely felt all those societal
pressures and familial expectations and
all that and so I mean part of it was
you know both my parents were professors
and then you know and it was just
expected that the kids are going to
college you know that my sister and I
would both go to school and get an
education so when you stopped out what
did your mom say well she was fairly
supportive well the thing is but it
wasn't that I was quitting
colleges that I was taking a semester
off and also that year I'd been invited
to Youth worlds like I've gotten second
national so it was kind of like oh you
know go to Scotland do youth were loud a
little bit in Europe or something like
take the semester off because it was
during this school semester and so it
was a really good excuse to take off a
few months like dad had just died I was
going the world it was all sort of like
you know things were a bit of a change
and so I took six months off and then I
just you know did I go back hit it but
so there was never a point where it's
like I'm never gonna go to college again
because I'm sure had I said that she
would have been a little bit more you
know resistant mm-hmm but um but then it
just sort of played out that now I'm no
I'm an old homeless person well yeah I
mean we just grew out of this thing that
you just loved yeah you know and there's
there's something really pure and
beautiful about that like it wasn't like
I'm gonna be the best climber in the
world you were just like this is what I
want to do yeah it's just uh you know
sort of put the path in front of me to
follow that like I'm gonna follow that
and I don't know it's funny because when
you're on the path and never you know
you never think you're following a path
right you know I was just like I was
living in a car living in tents just
going climbing a lot and it doesn't feel
like a path until many years later when
you look back you know I was very
committed to the time you're just like
what am i doing
yeah it's always that way I mean
hindsight's 2020 and it looks like
everything lined up perfectly for you in
this point but I think people under
appreciate how perhaps confusing it can
be when you're in that and you're not
quite sure you know
whether it's gonna be a left turn or
right - yeah sure how you're gonna
actually buy gas next week or any of
those things I mean in with climbing -
you climb a couple days and then you
have to take a rest and so when you are
young and unemployed and uneducated and
you're taking rest is you're like what
am I doing with my life you know cuz
like you have to rest because physically
your whole body hurts but on the days
where you're not climbing you're like
what what am i doing you know I'm not
climbing and I'm not doing anything else
and I've like my life sucks but there's
a key like what they call it the
dirtbags right yeah yeah sort of thing
so there's support within that group
kind of that was never my scene that
much that I mean obviously I am full you
know I would be a karmic tenures but um
but I was never big into the hippie
lifestyle climbing you know the dudes
hanging out smoking weed around the
campfire I joined the Stars like that
was never really my scene I think
because I grew up in a climbing gym and
I've always cared a little bit more
about the performance side of climbing
and climbing well but but that's what
makes you a LeMat ik of the next
generation you know it's sort of like
you could see the same thing in surfing
right totally
yeah the old lifestyle dudes that are
like I'm on the beach you having a good
time and then the younger guys you come
up and they're like athletes yeah trying
to you know go to the next level with
all I know it kind of makes sense that
you just can't really reach the next
level without a higher commitment or
performance mm-hmm you know and that's
why I mean the climbing's in the
Olympics in 2020 which is kind of a big
thing for this boy
how do you think about that I'm excited
about it it'll be cool I mean it has
nothing to do with me because I'm too
old and too weak and you know I won't be
any I'm hoping to be a commentator
sometimes I just want to go inspect it
but um I think it'll be amazing though I
mean the people competing are going to
be amazing climbers but it's it's the
natural kind of evolution of these kinds
of sports but you always see a little
bit of resistance with the old guard who
are trying to protect that purity yeah I
don't know you know I'm just not quite
old enough I guess for that I'm excited
I think it'll be cool yeah I'm off for
sure watch it it's gonna be pretty cool
I met you first at the screening of
Valle uprising in LA and that that movie
was super interesting because it kind of
addressed that that that sort of change
of the guard
yeah it really looked at the it unpacked
that history of what developed and
somebody is a good place to see that the
generational change because you somebody
is like each generation of climbers has
been so distinctly different and it's
it's really played out you know on the
same walls for 50 years right it's
pretty cool so are there are young kids
that you're aware of coming up right now
where you're like oh my god
not quite yet yeah but I think but I
think that the big wall traditional
climbing scene in the seventies sort of
lags behind the gym climbing scene
mostly because you get really really
strong in the gym and then you start
sort of taking that outside on more
adventurous things like the wall see you
somebody mm-hmm so I kind of think that
the next generation of u7t climbers are
so a few years out right but but we buy
the Olympics Olympics certainly in
within five years I would expect to be
seeing some stuff that's yeah yeah it's
really exciting well there's no question
that you've inspired you know the next
generation of young kids who want to
come up and um yeah they're definitely a
couple people that I did I'm you know a
little plays out right so can we talk
about El Cap a little bit yeah I mean
let's I mean come on dude like I just
throw awesome I can't even like my hands
just thinking about it my hands start
sweating and I can't
I can barely bring myself to like watch
the footage it's just so nerve-racking
and I know that like this this was your
moment like this is something you
prepared for for a very long time and in
that lead-up like in that preparation
phase like what were you doing
specifically to wrap your head around
this that perhaps people aren't aware of
I don't know like what was the secret 20
years of hard work no um I mean you can
earn every foothold going all the way up
right almost I mean I knew all the ones
that mattered because I'm the easy
climbing you don't bother to memorize
stuff because you just climb it and it
feels like walking but on the harder
parts for sure I knew I knew everything
that mattered right and actually I still
know almost everything you know I still
remember almost all of it certainly all
the hardest parts that style totally
memorize mm-hmm
but um I don't know I mean it's yes the
lead-up I'm like where do I even
consider the lead-up starting or
finishing you know because I was I've
been thinking about it for so many years
and imagining it for so many years but
then I didn't actually start seriously
work
on it until the last sort of
year-and-a-half mm-hmm and then even
that I basically spent the fall season
and then the spring season when I
actually did it basically that year I
was actively training and preparing and
memorizing and you know what you would
think of is actually preparing yeah yeah
yeah I mean it's that that adage of you
know ask a master Paynter how long it
took them to paint the painting and
they'll tell you their whole life yeah I
mean I mean to some extent because I've
been thinking about El Cap since 2009 so
I mean that's you had been eight years
of dreaming about it mm-hmm and the
thing is it had taken me that long to
wrap my head around it and I wouldn't
have been able to start physically
preparing and actually training and
memorizing holds and doing all that
stuff if I didn't believe that it was
possible and it has sort of taken me
eight years to believe that it was
possible mm-hmm and and beyond the kind
of practical academic preparation and
the physical preparation for it do you
have specific visualization techniques
or mindfulness practices that you employ
a like prepare your brain to handle no
that's just another experience thing I
don't know so I've never I've never
meditated or anything I don't really
know mindfulness techniques you you know
anything like that but um but when I
visualize roots
I mean basically I just let my mind
wander through it and and I generally
gravitate towards the parts that I need
to so the harder parts you know I'll
just sort of think my way through
certain sequences or all imagining what
it'll feel like or but I mean a lot of
its just daydreaming you know thinking
about how happy you'll be when you grab
the final hold of a hard sequence or
like how amazing it'll be to get onto
the summit or conversely thinking about
how terrible would be to blow the left
foot and slip off the last move and fall
that you know fall from 2,500 feet or
whatever so I mean I'm definitely
thinking through and from the the crux
the the most difficult part of El Cap is
about 2,300 feet off the wall it's at
least 2,000 feet off the ground and uh
and it's only this 15 or 20 foot section
that's really difficult and it's got
very end right no with it's the it's the
crux of all the problem it's pitch 23
which is you know two-thirds of the way
up the wall and um and it's yes maybe 20
feet of difficult climbing it's pretty
hard and it has like some low angle
terrain beneath it so like if you fell
off you'd hit this kind of sloping ledge
you know 60 or 80 feet below you but
you wouldn't stop you know and so you
hit that and it'd be like a little
kicker and you'd shoot out maybe you'd
maybe land on El Cap spire which is 250
feet below you but obviously you dive if
you field 250 V or you would miss the
spire and go all the way to the ground
in which case you're really dead but
you'd probably still be alive as you
freefall for night you know like I fully
thought all that stuff through because I
mean it's important because like had
there been a bigger ledge then you'd be
like oh if I fell then I would just
stick the ledge and I wouldn't even
necessarily die and so then it would
kind of change your your you know the
the equation of risk and consequence and
all that you're like well if you're not
gonna die if you fall off a hard part
then it's like you don't need to be 100
percent solid in the same way uh-huh
in this case though you for sure die
over many of it you you have to live in
that reality and embrace it you think it
all through can't just be like well
that's not gonna happen so I'm not gonna
think about it like no you have to go
there and like no no I definitely go
there for everything I mean I think
about what it'd be like if it started
raining you know what would happen if
like my shoe tore in half or something
like one of my earliest sense of L cap
in two thousand six or seven I think one
of the first times that did free-rider
the route that I ultimately solid I
stepped on this particular foothold and
and it like cut a hole in my shoe
basically it's like a really sharp
little point and an icon the whole rest
of the route this big flapping hole in
my shoe but um you know that kind of
thing I mean it's important to think
about it like what happened there should
be torque you feel like that sucks
there's plenty of variables that you
can't control right so you you you do
your best to control all the things that
you have but you domain yeah you may not
be able to control them but you can at
least think them through so that if they
happen it's not like oh no no you're
like all right it's a crazy freak gust
of wind it doesn't matter really yeah I
mean I've matter well because I've
climbed in a lot of places with really
really strong wind and you just kind of
know what strong wind feels like and if
you think even 50 mile an hour wind as a
percentage of your body weight it's like
it's not that much force on you so you
can still climb at roughly the same
mm-hmm
the most the the most challenging thing
about wind is psychologically like
hearing the howling is like really frame
for your mind but I mean if you're
focused on doing something like wind
doesn't really matter that much so when
you're on the wall did was there any
misstep along the way or did you just
exit
you have this yeah everything was
everything's perfect yeah yeah though it
was interesting the morning of I didn't
feel you know particularly great like I
was kind of tired I sort of hit it right
at the end of the season we're like I've
been toiling hard for six weeks and
training and you know there's certain
point where it's like oh you peaked and
you're like definitely declining how I
was yeah you know I I don't think I hit
it quite at the peak peak I hit it sort
of at the beginning of the decline but I
mean which is fine because I was still
very very fit and I was still ready and
it was it's just the way at the timing
worked out but um but that morning it
was like a little bit overcast a little
bit cloudy so it stayed sort of humid
and warmer during the during the night
so when I started climbing it felt
really muggy and warm and like I was
hoping that it would be clear and crisp
and right and cool morning yeah but um
but it just wasn't and so part of me is
like oh these aren't perfect conditions
but I'm like who cares you know because
like I've climbed on the route in so
many different conditions I was like it
can be 10 degrees warmer it can be
slightly more humid like it doesn't that
doesn't matter did you feel a sense of
pressure though like I am coming off my
peak like I need to do this now I don't
want to wait another week or for the
weather to clear I mean not exactly
pressure pressure but yeah I mean part
of me just knew that if I wait another
week it was it was in June 3rd when I
did it and so the temperatures are only
getting hotter right and the season was
kind of winding down and uh and I mean I
was just I just knew I was ready my
shoes were perfectly broken in my skin
was good I was confident I just worked
on everything anything about waiting
another week is that then like I'd
actually been planning on doing it three
or four days before but it had rained a
little bit and so then I had to spend a
day repelling the wall again to make
sure that the rain hadn't disturbed like
I had some little tick marks like little
chalk markings on certain holes and key
places then to make sure I could find
them with my feet and things maybe
wanted to make sure the chalk hadn't
washed off in the rain and make sure
that none of the hard parts were wet so
but the problem is the hiking to the
summit and repelling the whole wall
makes you pretty tired and so then then
you have taken to the rest and then you
can you know this is one of the things
you're like oh yeah I could wait a
couple days for better weather but it's
like you know there's always gonna be
something yeah and then anything is that
you have to maintain a high degree of
fitness before you do it which means you
need to be training you need to be
climbing you need to be doing the other
thing
but that obviously makes you tired and
so you kind of have to nail it all
perfectly where it's like you've been
doing enough training that you feel
strong but you're not tired and right
now are not too tired right he's
actually I'd climbed and hiked the day
before but just a little bit of both
enough so that it was active and I felt
like my body felt good but I wasn't
tired tired uh-huh
I mean there's a lot it's a lot of magic
in it you know a lot of the secret sauce
we're gonna weigh he's a lot of it's
confidence and you just have to feel
good about it and what was what was the
the manner in which you kind of let
other people in on what you were doing
right I would imagine you had to be
pretty judicious about like who you're
sharing this you know goal with and and
and and being clear with how you're
gonna handle people who are gonna try to
talk you out of it yeah actually nobody
really tried to talk me out of it I mean
most of my my personal friends you know
weren't necessarily excited about the
idea they're always like oh really but
uh but nobody nobody was like you
shouldn't do that because you know they
all sort of respect my decision making
process and yes interesting though so
for the eight years I guess that I've
been dreaming about I'll cap I had never
really talked about it except for maybe
with a couple climbing friends is like
that would be an amazing dream but never
like I want to do that because it's just
a little too it's a little too much you
know and then um and then two years ago
I mean it's kind of a long story but
basically there's the whole process
making the film around it so Jimmy chin
and his wife tried bastard hailey and
approached me about doing a film project
like a documentary film like a feature
and which is a big opportunity for me as
a professional climber and like all
that'd be great like that's cool but the
only thing that I cared about filming on
or making a movie about was al cab and
in a way I was like it's kind of a
amazing opportunity to do justice to all
cab right you know because if any climb
in the whole world deserves a movie
about it its El Cap I mean it's the most
beautiful wall in the world it's like
that is a pinnacle climbing achievement
that you know should be documented in a
in a good way if it's if it's ever gonna
be filmed it should be done right I know
and so I kind of took it as a cool
opportunity to you know combine my
long-term dream with this big you know
professional opportunity and and in some
ways it was good to have a little bit of
its not added pressure
cuz I mean they didn't care about what
icon they just wanted to make a film
with me and I was the one it was like
we're doing out in El Cap because that's
what I want to do and they're like sweet
yes obviously that's a you know very
very photogenic wall but not but it was
a little bit good for me to have a
little extra you know to actually go and
start working on it
because you know without having ever
talked to anyone about it for years I
just kind of sat on it it's like oh
that's too big it's too big I don't know
and then once I started talking to my
friends about it and it became like a
film project and and then once it was
once we were filming then I started
talking to my friends more about it and
and then it became more real to me it
works on this is how yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then I started the real process of
like okay I'm working on it this is what
I'm doing and then I did it uh-huh and
and you have this you have a very
hangdog loose like kind of response to
all of this like as I recall like when
you get to the top you're like yeah oh
dude it's cool all right you know what's
next oh no no of everything I've come
into my life getting to the top of El
Cap I was hoping for even I mean even
right now I'm still like pretty psyched
I mean it's pretty amazing but yeah I
mean you have this nickname right like
no big deal like Alex no big deal I'm
sure you didn't you know um no but El
Cap was very meaningful to me for sure I
think it's probably the first thing I've
done in climbing that I'm that I'm
really proud of coming out it should be
September October cool is that National
Geographic or North Face um it's so
National Geographic or Fox's I guess
Jones it you know it's financed I
suppose right but basically it's it's a
try and Jimmy directing it and then you
know I don't know what combination of
partners will get it but it's already
committed to theaters and everything so
at least in movie theatres
right um festival style right short it's
like a it's like a movie movie right
well may route like made a big yeah so
that's actually the sort of viability of
movies like that yeah and so um it's
basically the same team that made Maria
making you know with bigger backers this
time and more more opportunity as making
hopefully a better version right and I
vote does it tell I'm sure it tells the
whole story behind it and like it was he
filming you like preparing
yeah yeah they were filming with me for
the two years that I don't know wow
that's exciting yeah I assume there's a
documentary about Antarctica right yeah
that'll be more like a traditional
climbing documentary I think it'll be
really good because it's so beautiful
but the Antarctica film will be much
more climbing specific I think the I
mean the elk at film will be in movies
you know it's designed so that someone
in Middle America that knows nothing
about rock climbing can go and see it
right and still be inspired and not
horrified right I think I hope no I'm
sure that's such a crossover event
because you don't have to know anything
about climbing to watch that and just be
astounded well that's kind of think it
is free so long is that it's easy for
people to understand you know you look
at it you're like wow that guy doesn't
have anything I wonder where those ropes
attached understand I know people always
ask how do you get the ropes up there
but if there's no rope then it's like oh
you just climb up there alright I used a
public stuff so what is that what is the
physical training look like for you
beyond just the climbing itself like do
you what other kind of prep do you do I
mean basically climbing and climbing
specific training which is a like
fingerboarding like hanging from small
edges and systematic ways different
grids dyes that your fingers and then
opposition's stuff you know so like
working your pushing muscles instead of
your pulling muscles just to keep from
getting injured mhm and then I was
actually doing a fair amount of
stretching before I'll cap just because
one of the key one of the hardest parts
on the crux is this big karate kick to
the left with you know it's just this
crazy maneuver where you have to put
your foot like way over there and so as
I got more flexible that that became
more secure mmhmm yeah it buffs finger
pull-ups yeah all that kind of stuff
yeah but um I mean for the six months I
guess preceding the actual real so maybe
the five months receiving the real solo
I was I was as I call it all in the
program you know so I was I was getting
like a weekly massage to help with
recovery my diet was was like pretty
locked and that busy didn't need any
sugar or anything
I had no supplemental dessert stuff for
you know five months I was basically
eating vegan diet but with egg still mmm
but um but very clean very wholesome
like not eating out that much just like
you know eating rice in
vegetable type meals and it was like I
was probably the leanest I've ever been
but part of that because I was doing a
lot of exercise so I was also just
learning a lot mm-hmm
but I think when I when I when I sent
the free router when would actually free
so it all cap I was probably three or
four pounds lighter than I normally am
but part of us just from all the hiking
and stuff too but yeah yeah I don't know
if I was very fit you know right uh
actually I was I just said I was in New
York for us couple days I was climbing
with him in the camera man one of the
very tape filmmaker guys that was
shooting with me for the actual ascent
and so he was the guy that walked to the
base with me and then was also on the
summit they see he filmed me taking off
the bottom and then he ran around and
made it to the top and then he was on
top when I got there uh-huh
just pretty cool but um it's got Claire
and that so I was climbing in the gym
with him because he's a rock climber
also and uh he was like ho when we saw
you in the spring like yeah we all were
all like whoa he looks fit like you know
he's been training which I mean I'm
always climbing and always training to
some extent but it was for me a
different level like a level of focus
and specificity for that particular well
and I think because I cared about the
objective so much more I was willing to
really you know people were you know
offering you cookies or something you're
like no I don't I don't need that you
know like I've got a goal and so what
does it all mean to you
like you it's it's been a moment you
know since that occurred like with a
little time and perspective like you
know how do you think about it and like
what is the significance of that for you
I don't know I mean I think I might need
another moment you know yeah it's funny
because I'm still talking about a lot in
the film project is still ongoing and
I've been doing a lot of talks around El
Cap and so it still feels pretty fresh
for me even though it's been six seven
months now but um I don't know I added a
couple chapters to my book so there'll
be a revised edition of my book coming
out right and so I've been writing a lot
about it I'm an editing you know it's
like I'm still very much in the world
the free rider and so I don't know I
mean but it's it's definitely the
biggest goal or project I've ever had in
climbing yeah it's definitely well I
think it holds significance for the
sport in general I mean it certainly
raises awareness about what you guys do
and and and you know I think it allows
people to have a level of appreciation
that there may be you know they don't
have because it's kind of a it's
weird mysterious subculture I mean any
non climber can definitely walk into you
so many Valley and look at the walls and
and just think oh my goodness like that
is outrageous
uh-huh I mean I kind of feel the same
way about I mean I was backing you
somebody in the fall and I look up at El
Cap and honestly it doesn't you know
even having having climbed without a
rope now it still looks so crazy like
yeah what an amazing law like that's so
cool I mean do you think like you know
when I was 15 or whatever like do you
think back to that young kid and and
think what would he think of what yeah I
mean yeah 10 or 15 years ago the first
times I looked at El Cap I thought it
looked totally crazy and now I mean it
looks a little bit less oh but you still
look at it you're like that's an
intimidating wall like that is a big
crazy wall yeah yeah like yeah I mean
you see people up there and it's like
little tiny dots and you're like wow
that's really big right yeah I mean what
is what is what do you think is like
behind it like what's driving you what
is the what's the motivation is it is it
love is it uh is it a sense of adventure
is it a competitiveness like what's that
psychology behind what motivates you to
do all this I don't know I mean it's a
lot of things I guess I mean part of it
is definitely trying to see what I can
do what I'm capable of I mean especially
with El Cap is it was something that I
felt like I was maybe uniquely capable
of doing in in this generation at least
I mean I'm sure people will do it in the
future more and you know it might not be
that crazy in 20 years but um but at
this point in time I was like if anyone
is gonna do this I think it could be me
if if I apply myself to and if I really
care about it and you know being the
first to do something like that I mean
was that that hasn't always been a huge
motivator for me for various projects
but for El Cap I mean I did kind of I
did kind of want that right now I was
like I mean you look at that wall and
you're just like I'm so proud yeah I
know and it's been all my years of
climbing looking at it is the ultimate
objective like the the pinnacle of rock
climbing and I was like that could you
know I could I could do that that could
be me and so then you know I sort of
felt obligated to try yeah I think
there's something that that uh is very
you know I keep using the word pure
that's not quite the right word
looking for like almost like a like a
childlike innocence about about you know
what you do it's so primal it's like
there's a mountain I'm gonna climb it
like it there's that it's element ah
yeah it's very base acre yeah and I
think to ask someone like yourself like
you know this I had Conrad on the show a
while ago and and you know I found the
same thing in him it's like if you ask
somebody like yourself like why do you
do what you do it's just like this is
who I am
no this is it's an expression of
something so deep and and so innate in
my personality and how I'm you know but
I mean for you it's it's a love for
somebody else they're like that's the
most terrifying thing I've ever seen
like I wouldn't go anywhere near yeah
that's fair I mean that's how I feel
like about singing you know if I should
go up on stage and sing I got I might as
well just kill myself like it would be a
disaster but a lot of people love you
know music performance any of that and
that's great I mean everybody has
something that they're passionate about
right so what else scares you that well
I don't know I mean that kind of stuff
is probably at the core of it you know
public performance yeah being perfect
you give talk songs but that's because
I've had a lot of practice now yeah I
used to be mortified of that it liked it
when I was in school if I had to give
some kind of presentation from in the
class like terror right you know right
just so embarrassed and so I don't know
yeah I mean I think that's like social
situations have always been the most the
most traumatize me for me let's talk
about a solos yeah I get it
let's talk about the diet stuff yeah you
want to talk about that yeah I want to
do a little bit I mean that's you tell
me you know well I don't know man like
tell me you know I I have a general
sense I think of where you're coming
from but I'm interested in in your
evolution your relationship with food
mm-hmm yeah well I mean so I been with
sharing for five years I think maybe
maybe a little more or less mm-hmm and
then throughout that I've sort of
dabbled with vegan hood from time to
time but never that seriously because
it's just hard with all the traveling
and just and especially gone on
expeditions and various things like in
Antarctica I was eating a bunch of meat
was so the reason I went vegetarian was
for the environmental impact
like trying to help the earth basically
and then it also read a bunch about
human health and performance stuff and
and then once I stopped eating me I
started caring more about the ethics a
bit which I guess kind of made sense
that once I stopped killing other
creatures that much then I started
caring more about their lives you know
but is one of the things that when I was
eating a lot of meat it was I was like
oh who cares about chickens you know but
then once I stopped I was like I'm glad
to not be not be killing creatures opt
out of yeah because yeah exactly like I
mean I try to do no harm in general like
I would never just kill some songbird
you know so it's like kind of the same
with with food was there like an
influence like a book or a person or so
a bunch of books I mean kind of all the
classic like China study type things I
don't know like yeah thrive the Brendan
Fraser oh yeah actually I don't think
I've actually read your book it's funny
I was reading through all the different
diet books I've read and I was like I
don't think I'll give you a copy yeah
yeah brant Brendan lives right up the
street yeah yeah yeah but like I know
Scott you're coming friends at the book
I read his stuff after I'd already gone
but sharing everything but um and so my
sister's been vegan for I don't know 12
or 14 years or something and uh and she
lives a very conscientious intentional
lifestyle like she lives in Portland
she's never owned a car she bicycles
everywhere she's very beachy and she's
super Portlandia yeah she's super
Portland yeah that's pretty classic but
I mean she's made very intentional
choices with their life too to minimize
her harm you know every which I which I
really respect and so that was always a
positive influence for sure for me
though it's it's all slightly more in
moderation you know I definitely call
myself vegetarian but like I was hanging
in an article I was eating meat yeah
like when we're at the Russian
logistical base we were getting served
by the Russian staff I mean it's like oh
the options are yeah we get kill or bug
soup yeah and I was kind of like well I
guess I'm having the pork soup because
Lisa has you know frozen vegetables in
it too it's like and um and
realistically you know because my goal
is always to minimize my impact I was
like if I eat meat from time to time
when it's like the thing that there is
to eat I'm like that's fine I'm still
minimizing ninety percent my impact
that's that's good enough and then yeah
but that's basically my dietary you know
like minimizing my heart right right
right yeah it's interesting I mean I
think it's a natural extrapolation of I
mean you you point your sister is living
this you know low impact no impact
minimalist lifestyle but you know your
your life is pretty emblematic of that
as well like it's it's minimal well I
just bought a house right yeah famously
been living in for a long time but I
travel so much though that I mean in
terms of impact like the you know in
terms of carbon emissions like my my
footprints outrageous you know though I
kind of deal with that in other ways but
but I mean I definitely have a big
impact on the earth and that's part of
the reason that I look for things like
diet like any kind of personal choices I
can make to minimize that impact I feel
they're pretty important for me and
you've always I mean how long did you
live in the van
well I mean ten years I guess but yeah I
mean last year I bought this house in
Vegas but then I still spend six months
in the van because then I went to eat
seventy for two months and then we my
girlfriend that road-tripped around and
the Northwest for two months in the
summer and then I was back in the valley
and the fall so I mean I was in the band
for six months uh-huh
I'm so glad that you did drive the van
here yeah yeah I came from New York
though so yeah no I know and you know
baked into that really is you know
living living light in the sense of like
you're not accumulating a bunch of
possession like you just want to climb
you're trying to the idea behind it
really is like strip away everything
non-essential yeah distractions so that
you can spend the most amount of time
doing the thing that you love yes most
important - yeah for sure right like
what do I want to be doing and what do I
need to do to do that and then
everything else is just sort of
superfluous right but I would imagine as
your profile continues to rise that
there are more and more pressures on you
to you know hey come do this or yeah
come here and and it all sounds awesome
right but all of those things are kind
of related to what you love and and
perhaps they inform it or inspire other
people to get more involved in and
excited about this thing that you love
but ultimately it's taking you away from
the thing yeah I mean you've had to deal
with all that - huh yeah it's like
almost wellness is making me unwell yeah
it's it's that classic thing of like oh
well what's more important like me going
out on a trail run or going and getting
in front of a thousand people to talk
about like this lifestyle you have to
balance that right yeah and it's and
sometimes its heart it's it's like hard
for me personally to say no and I've had
to learn how to get better at that
no I struggle with us up to I mean I
choked with a lot of my friends that
being a professional climber makes you a
worse climber you know because the spine
yeah yeah being a professional climber
mean you were you can't the dirt bag
exactly yeah being a dirt bag all you do
is climb so you're pretty good at
climbing right but I mean but the
obviously there's balance because being
a professional you get paid to go to
cool places you get you know you broaden
your climbing experience and you know
for me it's important that that I make a
living I can stay for the future like
because I don't want to be a 75 year old
dirtbag living in my car with like no
health insurance just like struggling
you know like you know I'm very grateful
that I'm able to save and that you know
someday I'll have a family and it should
be like a relatively comfortable
lifestyle and stuff and you know that I
mean yeah I'm glad for that but I still
just want to go climb all the time right
right right why why did you get a house
in Vegas I think it's the buddies yeah
everybody's like wife Vegas especially
seems overseas or like but I think it's
the best condom in the country really
straight up but on the climb that it's
great for climbing it's like always good
there's Tommy to altitude so when it's
hot you just go higher and it's totally
fine also the housing is cheap so it's
easy to get a place there there's no
income tax or just kind of and the thing
is I mean where else you know like where
I don't know I mean we're like I don't
know Boulder I guess or we're all there
I see so you can't just like buy a
casual house in Boulder unless you're a
millionaire or living near Yosemite yeah
but I don't I don't like the cemani
housing situation because anywhere that
you can live near Yosemite is still a
40-minute drive into the valley and so I
would still just want to stay in the
valley with my van and and deal with you
know deal with the valley camping
situation because I just don't like
having to drive back and forth all the
time yeah there was that thing in valley
uprising where you had to you have to
park your yeah I'm like outside the
perimeter yeah exactly I mean there are
a lot of different ways you can pay for
the camping in the pay campground so
there are different things you
do but but everybody sort of finds their
own path and you somebody and and
they're there definitely ways to make it
work mm-hm
but the thing about living forty minutes
out is that it's not even in a city then
and it's like no not like their
restaurants or anything to do it's like
you're just in some cabin in the woods
but I still drive super far right so I
would rather live like where I live in
Vegas I can walk across the street to a
bunch of different ethnic restaurants
and it's actually I think it's like the
only neighborhood in Vegas that's
walkable this is a grocery store across
the street there's a bunch of
restaurants is everything I need and
there's other is there's a climbing
community yeah there's a good climb
between you have a lot of friends there
you know it's ten minutes to mountain
biking trails and it's like 20 minutes
to the climbing 15 minutes of climbing
right and the climbing gym is four
minutes it's normally one track and I
groove home listening to music you know
on the drive there you have one big song
get psyched up and then you get to the
gym the climb I mean it's pretty it's a
good situation for me but now you're in
a position where it's like oh now I need
furniture and now I need like I'm just
gonna go sleep in the van we know it so
when I bought the house actually at the
time my girlfriend was abroad and and so
I did just I got a Wi-Fi router and then
I would just sit in this empty
unfurnished home to use my laptop and
then I realized that the service was
just as good in the van on the driveway
and I was like oh screw it I'm just
sitting on the driveway yeah
knowing I didn't how I had no
possessions nothing in the house I just
had you know my Wi-Fi is that up and
I'll just live in the van on the
driveway huh and then after a week or
two or whatever when she came back then
we acquired a bed and you know piece by
piece right right right
oh yeah you got a house now let's talk
about the foundation a little bit I mean
this I think it's a natural segue
because you know we're talking about
minimalism low impact you know you know
you're the same year that I went
vegetarian I started the foundation
right it was basically a year I was like
I need to start trying to do something
positive for the world and so I thought
that the three things I was going to do
that year we're start this foundation
like start donating money to charity and
start offsetting my travel like doing
carbon offsets and then and then go
vegetarian and and then the carbon
offsets I want to sort of ignoring and
rolling that into my foundation because
as I looked into it more I realized that
you're basically financing projects that
I'd rather just finance myself through
the foundation just do it more
rather than going through a third party
carbon offset mm-hmm and so yeah I'm so
basically that year I want vegetarian I
started the foundation which at the
beginning was just me donating money in
a public way to environmental nonprofits
huh
and then actually just this year we're
trying to sort of rebrand it as like a
real thing that I'm more comfortable
being public about and the idea behind
it is environmental preservation yeah so
I think that I think the mission
statement now is supporting solar energy
for a more equitable world mmm that's
good who talked with that several of us
and it took quite a bit uh it took more
effort than it probably should have huh
but but the solar the solar aspect of it
or the solar focus of it is is kind of
Dhiraj from this carbon offset idea
right like well partially well actually
no no really it comes from me looking
for projects I mean so when it started I
was just like what do I want to donate
money to that will make the world a
better place and so I started looking
for things that was sort of win-win he's
basically there's no point in supporting
environmental projects that don't also
improve human standard of living because
if people are living in poverty they do
not care about environmental protection
and so basically I was looking for
environmental projects that also help
people in poverty or improve people's
livelihood and so and solar just fits
that so perfectly
I mean solar projects or energy access
type projects are such an easy way to
produce clean energy which is a clear
environmental gain but also help people
materially and so I started supporting
basically one group in domestically
which was grid alternatives and then one
group in Africa which is solar in doing
off-grid basically it's like grid tied
solar systems versus off-grid solar
systems and just started supporting both
of those just because they seem like
such obvious winners you know I was like
this is making the world better and then
over the last five years I guess that
I've been supporting them you know we've
branched out into some other projects
and tried some one-off things our own
and you know worked in the space more
but this Solar has always been the
thread through it and so now we've sort
of just made that our actual mission
statement right that's cool I like that
I mean it's all a work in progress but
um but I think this year we're actually
starting to beat more like I've never
solicited donations I've never actually
asked people to donate to the foundation
I've always just
put it out there's like this is what I'm
doing and this is you know my effort to
try to do something positive in the
world but I think that this year watch
you start trying to solicit donations to
basically support bigger projects and
you should so you when you say we you
have a team of people yeah so from the
beginning I've had this friend of mine
Mari Birdwell who's the executive
director but now but basically as a
climber who's an attorney in Boulder
who's you know a friend and then and
then sort of starting this last year
they're two other women involved that
are both they've brought a lot of energy
to it there are a lot more go-getter and
they're kind of making this all happen
more because you know I've always just
been content donating a big chunk of my
my income every year and just being like
okay you know I've I've done something
positive that's great I'm supporting
these projects but I've never felt super
comfortable pushing it really hard or
asking people for money or or soliciting
big you know grants from from the
companies that work with or anything and
so I think they're sort of helping to
bring the vision together and yeah and
make it more public well you know just
do even if you have the greatest team
ever
you're still the face of it like you're
gonna have to get to a place where
you're comfortable yeah I think look man
this is a good thing like you know break
out the wallet yeah well I think that's
kind of I think I'm getting there and
honestly I think El Cap is actually tied
into that a lot because I'm I'm a lot
more comfortable being a professional
climber I haven't done something that
I'm actually very proud of yeah that I
feel like I've worked very hard for and
it was that was legitimately big
challenge and and I definitely have a
bigger platform and certainly with a
movie coming out this year it's gonna be
probably a whole different wash and so
it's just kind of good timing for me
personally and professionally to be more
public about the foundation and and
honestly I mean that I mean the world
needs it you know like yeah I mean I
mean you've traveled to places you know
most people will never go right like so
you have a sense of you know the
environment and and kind of have a have
a perspective you know a global
awareness perspective that a lot of
people have you know because we just
don't travel like we you do I mean what
is you you know what do you learn when
you go to the far reaches of the planet
I've actually never really thought about
this but it's interesting that through
climbing I've kind of seen the full
spectrum both environmentally and in
through human society because I've been
to some of the poorest places on earth
where you see human populations living
in rugged conditions which is you know
this is like Chad or places in you know
basically sub-saharan Africa but like
right on the edge of the desert it's
like really really grim living
conditions or very challenging
conditions where you I mean it's just
shocking to see people living you know
you're like wow really right but then on
the other end I've also been to places
like going back to Patagonia in multiple
years where each year you go you see the
glaciers receded a couple hundred meters
to the point where just over the three
years that I've been to Patagonia the
approach into one of the valleys has
changed significantly like you now hike
on the opposite side of the valley
because the glacier has moved so much it
makes more sense to come and the other
side now and I'm just over the course of
your show yeah just over the course of
me going Patagonia for four or five
years remember which is crazy because um
and then you come back to the US and
people are like no you know climate
changes in a thing and you're kind of
like I mean you can go to the mountains
and you can see the glaciers moving
backward and that ms just in my tiny
tiny little life span which should be
insignificant in the grand scheme of the
earth so you're like if if humans can
physically see change with their own
eyes I mean that's that's a disaster
right you know that's that's crazy on a
disaster it's it's evil and it's so
disheartening to see you know the
situation that we find ourselves in
where there isn't you know very much
political will to confront it yeah I
think right now - right like I know the
solar tariff thing is pretty crazy
though I don't know favor of solar like
it's no no no well it's interesting
because you know the term administration
is trying to protect solar manufacturing
in the u.s. versus but it's like solar
installation is such a bigger driver of
jobs and better for the economy just way
more important but I mean whatever the
thing you the best of the I kind of
think you know I'm no expert in this
whole industry but I think that's more
like a little speed bump that's like
that's annoying and that's stupid and
it's short-sighted but it's not gonna
change the overall trajectory which is
that every every structure in America
will have solar on it within you know 15
years or something yeah and like it's
all happening no matter what and that's
actually kind of what bothers me is that
to me it seems clear that that's an
inevitable trend that's happening like
renewable energy is it's just cheaper
you know everybody will go 100%
renewable
within the next 50 years because that's
just the way that's the way it is but
it's like too bad we can just do it in
15 years instead of 50 right you know
and save ourselves a lot of frickin
climate disaster down the road yeah I
mean it's like so frustrating the people
can't just do a little faster so quickly
I mean if if there was a real will for a
for sure I mean there are certain areas
in China where they're just crushing it
in that regard so it's weird that
they're like leading the charge well I
mean I think in some ways it's great
because I mean they're far more people
in China - and so it's true and I mean
somebody needs to lead and it's like if
the US wants to abdicate that the
opportunity you know just like give up
the I mean it's disappointing that the
US isn't leading but I'm like as long as
somebody does that's great because
humanity needs a leader and so yeah I
mean it it we definitely do and it's a
it's a race against time you know the
idea that you could see that change in a
blink of an eye like I know it's crazy I
mean there's one Valley in Patagonia
it's like yeah I mean you know this is
anecdotal it's not it's not real science
but still you're like though I mean it I
mean the opposite is real science you
can go in at Sierra and you can see that
the glacier having have you ever seen
any of the glaciers of the Sierra there
there are a couple in the palace it's
like some of the 14,000 foot peaks and
the Sierra Nevada and California
technically have glaciers but um it's so
sad you go up now and you're like oh
that tiny little snow field that's the
palisade glacier you're like huh like
that's not you know yeah that's not what
people think of when they think of a
glacier it looks like a dirty snow patch
you know and in a couple years it'll
probably be gone it will just become
seasonal snow patches well I think I
mean you're you're in a unique position
to be you know a sort of spokesperson
for this with all the things that you've
accomplished and you know your ability
to get up in front of people and as
somebody that you know people respect
and admire you know to to take that to
you know shoulder that responsibility
and take that on I you know I mean I try
to do that as much as I can and you know
that's sort of why I like social media
and having a platform is because I'm
able to talk about issues that I think
are really important yeah but um but you
do get such backlash and such criticism
and so much you got all the shift for
going to the window
well it's because there were signs in
those pictures is like the last sign in
the image in the series of images said
uh I'd called Trump a chemical occurs
you can yeah I'd called Trump a [ __ ] but
he lacks the warmth and depth uh-huh
who's like which you know like it's free
funny but uh that was like an old woman
but at that sign I think I don't know my
girlfriend took all the pictures and
stuff and then I just sort of took some
of the ones that I thought were funny
and put them into a slideshow but I mean
it gets like a lot of criticism for
people and I'm like yeah I understand
that that sign is it's crude it's vulgar
and it's not respectful to the
presidency but I'm like you know that is
free speech like you know I wouldn't
necessarily like I wouldn't I would
never hold that sign like that's not the
message that I want to necessarily but
at the same time it's the women's March
I mean come on
I mean basically it's a bunch of women
you know trying to advocate for equal
rights basically and and rights for you
know minority groups and they're trying
to register people to vote and I'm like
all of those things should be
fundamental for a functioning democracy
like this I know it's like weird that
stuff becomes so partisan because really
you know if everybody votes democracy is
functioning at its best you know I mean
the whole point of democracy is for
everybody to express their opinions and
so like Alex you're a climber stay in
your lane just no I just want pictures
of you on the rocks
I know that stuff Festo's well I I
appreciate that point of view and I mean
I you know I try to post a lot of
climate pictures but like what's the
point and do it what's the point having
a platform if not talking about the
things that matter yeah particularly
when they I mean it's the freaking rest
day in Vegas I went to do cool cool
cultural events my girlfriend it's like
that's awesome I know shame on you know
I know yeah I mean if I went to like a
cool Natural History Museum and posted
something about the museum it's like
yeah exactly you know yeah be like oh I
went to this cool thing you know I want
to share that but um I think it just
speaks to you know the heightened
emotional state that we're in and the
the extent of the polarization you know
it's yeah so I generally try to I try to
craft my my messages whenever I get
political or you know talk about diet or
talk about any of the stuff that I care
about and parmitano is there anything I
generally try to be relatively moderate
and respectful about it because the
thing is that people just unfollow you
or turn you off then it's like you're
only preaching to the choir
you know I'm like I don't need to talk
to the choir I need to talk about the
people that disagree I definitely know
with and so that I mean I typically try
to make things pretty mellow because I
want people to listen to it you know
yeah and you I mean on the diet tip like
I've heard you speak about it from time
to time but you don't put it out in
front you know you're pretty low-key
about the whole thing well that's also
because I mean I do eat meat sometimes
yeah okay I don't want to preach about
you know like being vegan is the way I
mean I do agree that if everybody ate a
vegan diet the world would be a better
place straight up but you know sometimes
I eat pizza and I'm like others right
you know it's like dairies not even that
good for me like I think I'm lactose
intolerant but from time to time like
it's pretty tasty you know it's like you
know it's okay and do you get grief for
that I'm talking about diet stuff yeah I
mean yeah kind of
certainly if I post them like Pro
vegetarian thing people like oh stay out
of you know right I don't know so
actually I feel like how do you like
mentally you know manage like the the
haters oh I'm a certain point you just
like FML oh my god not yet okay what was
interesting so the women's March was the
biggest backlash I've ever had from
anything on social media like magazine
even like wrote an ROI you know yeah
that stuff seems kind of silly but but I
was actually kind of glad that it got
picked up in various places because the
point of me posting about it is was to
give it a wider wider reach and so you
know I'm glad for more people to see it
more people to think about it more
people to think about those issues I'm
like that's I mean that's the point
having a rally to have people talk about
it right but anyway though um I think
that like 3,000 people unfollowed me
after the women's March which you know
you're like oh wow there's a lot of
people on following but at the same time
that's like half percent or less than
half a percent I'm like that just does
not matter you know yeah it's like it's
just it just
life goes on to me like okay he went to
a women's March a lot of women's rights
like no no I want no part of you anymore
a lot of people saw it as me being a
pro-abortion
so I mean the people that think that I'm
advocating the murder of babies I'm like
yeah I can see how that's really
offensive to people like I respect that
but um but me saying that I think that
women should be able to choose their own
reproductive option you know like be in
control of their own bodies or whatever
is a lot different than saying I think
people should murder babies you know I
mean and it's just too bad that that
people conflate those online
right whatever this is the you know this
is the social media world and we uh you
know I know it's so funny that you know
I post a picture of a sign that says
that the women should be in charge of
their own bodies and people like you
want to murder babies and you're like no
I mean it's like if I personally was a
woman that got pregnant like I mean it
would be a big decision like I don't
know if I personally would want to abort
a baby because you know I like in the
same way that I don't eat meat and I
don't necessarily want to kill other
creatures I'm like I don't know if I
would kill you know like I don't know if
I would feel comfortable killing
something at the same time I'm like I'm
not gonna tell other people not to I'm
like Jesus I mean it's their lives you
know like they need to I don't know
right just like yeah it's just this it's
pretty heavy you know I'm like ha yeah
you're advocating murder yeah I don't
think so like it's a pretty weird
interpretation I thought it was funny
that then then the next day you posted a
climbing picture yeah and I was like f
all you picture yeah no I was very proud
of that
uh-huh but I kind of loved stirring the
pot like that a little bit huh I mean
that's the whole I mean that's how civil
society should work you know people
should exchange ideas and talk about
things and you know broaden their
opinions and stuff well the thing is
like if you if you're able to develop a
platform and you have an audience of
people with that comes a certain
responsibility to speak your truth and
if that doesn't land you know well with
certain people like so be it
yeah you know otherwise what's the point
yeah yeah no exactly otherwise you're
basically being held hostage by the mob
right now you're just like on you the
way we want yeah I'm like not screw that
I'm gonna be me I'm gonna do my thing
alright well I want to talk a little bit
about like the practical aspects of like
how you live this life like I assume
like I'm trying to understand like how
this all works like you have North Face
as a sponsor they pay you you do
commercials you use all these sorts of
things you get paid in all these various
ways and that all kind of comes together
to make it work is that that's questions
yeah that's pretty much it I have like a
manager I have an agent / manager the
deals and so all the little things that
you're talking about like commercials or
corporate speaking gigs or even my
sponsorship money that all kind of goes
through the agent yeah I said then I'm
just getting you know direct deposits
from all right so he says like here's
good one or what about filters out yeah
like whatever stuff yeah exactly and
it's it's kind of an interesting thing
on the sponsor level
I mean North Face I mean that's an
amazing company like I love how they
support all these different interesting
athletes and and that like the athletes
summit then they do like yeah I mean
that's basically just the team meeting
but it's pretty amazing because you get
to hang out with all these people
they're so great in different fields and
so it's pretty inspiring yeah that's
cool I had a bunch of those do you know
Dean Karnazes yeah that who else do you
know Brogan Graham yeah podcast
Timmy Olsen yeah yeah runner yeah it's
cool but on the other hand you have like
these other sponsors who are sort of
creeping away from this high risk world
like you know it's relevant to the
social media thing because we're in this
kind of you know environment in which
you know it's got to be crazier and it's
got to be wilder and x-games and you
know wingsuit people and all you look
exact same stunts you know and it's like
what's the next thing what's the next
thing to the point where it was cliff
Bart right that like pulling back and
said we can't be part of this anymore
it's getting too hectic for us yeah was
those I think in 2014 but that's the
only sponsor that has ever dropped me
and it was part of that like purge that
they did for the yeah yeah it was post
Valley Uprising been released hmm and
they dropped D Potter and C to write and
to mewni own and stuff Davis so like
they see the five of us that sort of
represented the extreme danger climbing
or whatever but um but then the next
year Dean did die in an accident no and
so you know obviously they're at least
somewhat correct about risk-taking I
mean we are doing things that are
dangerous there's playing these people
and then they feel some pressure you
know maybe not a not like you know over
pressure but internally to like push the
envelope pushing into I'll have that on
their hands if something happens yeah
III don't know this for sure but um but
the cliff thing I think part of that was
I think Gary the the owner cliff has
personally really opposed to free
soloing and so I think it wasn't
necessarily the brand is totally opposed
but but Gary was like I'm not into this
this is a bad deal or something you know
like I kind of think there was some kind
of backs
I don't know it yeah yeah and I'm not
really that concerned about it because I
mean it's totally fair for them to not
you know yeah I mean I really
appreciated their support and then and
then once they fired me they were
actually really cool about it too they
still send me free product and they paid
out my contract and it was all pretty
legit I was like it's cool I still get
free product it's all good so um I mean
I have no hard feelings at all but um
yeah I mean every brand sort of makes
makes their own decision you know yeah
no no though I mean interestingly so I
sort of mentioned that I came from the
beyond meat office is right oh yeah
that's right so I mean this is kind of a
good little example of how how my whole
lifestyle works is like so they sort of
reach out about maybe I don't know
they've talked to my agent manager a bit
about maybe some kind of Spartacus
sponsorship or partnership or something
I got to know exactly right but um but
since I'm gonna let it made sense to go
meet them and see the whole crew and eat
though no yeah it was awesome yeah yeah
and so uh I got a full you know buffet
of all their products they were super
delicious I was really into it has he
gone meat before not really they'd sent
some to my address but I think I was on
expedition my girlfriend ate it and I
don't know I just never never really
tried it and so that's kind of an
example you know I might wind up with
some kind of a life yeah allowing your
sponsors with things that you're you're
interested in yeah exactly consistent
and that is like very much something
that my understand because I really do
think that's the future I mean I kind of
think that's the only way the humans
will be able to live well on earth is if
we you know move away from animal
agriculture stuff well it's just cool to
like align your professional career with
your values yeah way and I sure I would
imagine you're somebody who's in a
position where you you have the ability
to pick and choose and say you know this
does this I don't this message isn't I'm
not down with it you know you're gonna
be with companies that are like on the
same page that I'm on like if a soda
company comes money but a commercial
you're just like no like I'm not gonna
tell people they should drink more soda
I don't even think they should be buying
more cans you know let alone those the
discussing sugar inside them right it's
like ya know or like a tobacco company
don't freakin that you know Hans
fluorine he was like a big speed climber
kind of previous generation but the two
of us held the speed record on the nose
together
right up until last year got broken
couple months ago but um so Hans was
like mr. El Cap speed record for for
many many years and uh but he's also
that older me and has been through the
whole pro climbing thing a lot longer
every time we would hike down from the
top of El Cap together we would sort of
debrief about what we did
performance-wise on the nose and sort of
talk about what we should do better and
then sort of talk you know climbing in
life in general and he was talking about
having gone to Asia to do cigarette
commercials like in the nineties or
something and he was like ah you know in
Asia is not as bad I was like you didn't
see commercials in Asia but I mean but
it was also it was a different time oh
my god yeah he was like on making a
living and he is a family and everything
and he's like raising kids yeah you know
what I was like hon you did a cigarette
commercial that's freaking discreet it's
like what you know do that stuff in
Japan well I've done some stuff like
that where yeah you do some campaign
like like I did a whiskey commercial or
it was more like a brand new he's really
right yeah I know and they didn't even
get it was awesome it was it was a
Dewar's ad which actually trying to turn
out being awesome that's like a really
great piece it lived online for three
years or something it was good money is
like really good professionally but ah
yeah it was just you know some lifestyle
poor anything they like didn't care that
I like there's no mention of liquor in
the ad there's no it was all about
lifestyle like you know choosing your
path or whatever but um yeah I was like
well only people people are only seeing
in Europe so like at least it's not too
embarrassing yeah I mean I I don't have
judgment on athletes that make decisions
like that it's like they just want to do
their sport and and it's why I judge a
little bit I mean some of those things
I'm like Oh cigarettes like that's well
that's sort of a page beyond I think
yeah though I mean people could
certainly criticize alcohol in the same
way but um but I was like oh it's like
high-end scotch or whatever like that's
not contributing to people drinking more
it's sort of like they're vying for
market share between maybe this is doers
so well you know I don't know like I I
would think the soda actually would be
worse than that my question about that
but what's cool is that you know with
them as the Millennials come of age
we're seeing this crop of like companies
that are premise thanh transparency and
sustainable you know triple bottom-line
values and all of that and so the
options I think become you know better
for someone
yourself to align with you know
like-minded Souls so that you can keep
doing what you're doing and you can feel
good about you know the companies that
are supporting ya like going into the
beyond me at office today was a perfect
sample like the posters the the quote
you know the things on the wall
everything I was like this whew you know
like it could all be up in my house like
this is awesome is totally in line you
know they're having a massive impact I
mean I hope so mmm yeah it's cool to
even the idea of working with a company
like that that you want to succeed like
I would love for them to take over the
world just because it would make the
world a better place you know like yeah
you get rid of freaking billions and
cows like that's good for everybody yeah
there's no question about that
yeah well cool man we only have a couple
more minutes here but before we before
we close it down you know I'm interested
in in in how you choose your adventures
like what is the selection process is it
just like a instinctual like that sounds
cool I'll do that or do you put a lot of
thought and intention into like okay
what's my next move because there's got
to be some pressure like oh well you did
Al Capp so now you know what's the next
crazy thing you're gonna do or is that
not part of the calculus no this is some
combination in the two I mean it's it's
largely what's inspiring you know I mean
El Cap has always been the most
beautiful inspiring like that is such a
clear objective but then I am pretty
meticulous about having journals and
to-do lists and things and so you know I
make a list of potential goals and then
obviously it makes sense to organize
them in a way that maximizes fitness and
things you know like if you're trying to
do something it's very short and hard
you do that before doing something
that's like long and easier you know to
build things so physiologically you're
actually capable of doing the things
that you want to do and then some of it
has to do with weather and fitness and
timing you know like where will you be
at certain times of the year and how
does that play into work and so I mean
I'm kind of constantly evaluating
different potential goals and so
something that I might really want to do
just like doesn't make sense to do this
year because I won't have the
opportunity because I don't have the
time required or I won't be in like I've
always wanted to climb and in trango is
like this valley in Pakistan it's like
big walls at high altitude is really
beautiful and I will definitely go there
sometime in my life but um but not this
year
you know it's like it just doesn't make
sense with the schedule and the stuff
going on and
like real life so what is this thing
don't know
I mean basically I've been trying to get
stronger like I've been I've been
training systemically in a gym yeah look
big man do I mean you're like you
definitely look you when you walked in
the door I was like he's like a little
more like jacked up and then I was
expecting yeah I've been lifting some
way yeah actually a new thing yeah it's
a very new thing yeah why I came home
from Antarctica the heaviest I've ever
been and kind of fat man style a little
bit it was little because the month
before the trip I mean I kind of said I
was slightly depressed about the trip I
was like I don't know I wasn't I wasn't
excited about going I knew it was a
great opportunity and you know knew
would be cool but I was like oh man it's
gonna be cold I'm not gonna be climbing
it wasn't you know but so anyway the
month before I went I wasn't training
that much and I was eating a lot because
I was trying to gain some weight before
Antarctica because it seemed appropriate
and then while I was there I a lot
because you're in Antarctica and and
part of it was just uh what do you call
it like like when you're comfort eating
you know I was just because you have a
really so much traumatic data climbing
and you come home and back to camp and
you're just like I'm this whole thing in
atella you know because I just want to
eat something to feel better it was it
was pretty raw there I mean I thought it
was pretty full on but um so I came home
and I was like oh like I'm actually like
kind of have you kind of want it just
like it's the first time I've ever been
it was the heaviest over been a couple
pounds overweight I mean I'm talking a
few pounds here and there not like ten
but um anyway so now I've try to start
at the systematic training type of stuff
and I'm seeing with a drainer on that or
how do you get your information on the
protocol so I mean I guess you could say
I do uh so a good friend of mine this
got Jonathan Siegrist who's one of the
best sport climbers in the country like
really under the radar like no non
climber knows knows who he is but he's
one of the best programmers in the world
but um he he's a good friend of mine
he's also living in Vegas and so I'm
paying him a bit as my trainer this
season and the thing is I know how he's
been training last couple years and has
had really great success for him and so
I'm like god I'm doing this I'm
committed to it but it's actually been
quite helpful having him kind of guide
me through the process because a lot of
is like form and how I do the exercises
and like making sure that I maintain
good shoulder health by like how I hold
my arms
user and things things like that but
what is it but a functional strength
stuff or it's actually lifting weights
and in a gym or you know the lifting the
ways is just for opposition type
training that makes you know to balance
out basically I'm hanging off small
edges with a bunch of weight on I see
I'm so I don't know what you call that
but yeah but you're on that right but
just not with extra not with extra
weight that extra weight has made it
quite a bit different for me but so I'm
almost done with my first cycle and the
the each each cycle is like a month
roughly and the last two days I was
climbing in the gym in New York I was
like slightly off my program because I
was travelling but um is the first two
days where I was like oh my goodness
this is working and it's pretty exciting
I was like I felt really strong in the
gym it was like wow so yes so what does
that translate into does that like
change okay well now that I feel like
this like maybe I'll go do this climb
it'll take a lot more it'll take like
right now I'm sort of feeling as strong
as I ever feel I'm gonna do at least one
more training cycle for the month of
February and hopefully that'll break
into new ground where I'm like oh my
goodness I've never been so strong and
then I'll sort of evaluate right but I
have a couple goals and you seventy this
season that lend themselves to being
strong so I'm like that's helpful and
then yes like a cyclist no you got to be
careful about power-to-weight right like
you can't get too big yeah well I've
actually been losing a little weight as
like the thing is holding weights while
you hang I mean my forearms we're never
gonna get that big a cyclist has to
worry about it because it's their butt
and their thighs and it's like big
muscles but a climber I mean your
forearms you're never gonna be that big
because I mean mostly I'm training my
hands right but if you start getting you
know big shoulders and lats and you know
but you're packing on all this muscle
the mountain right yeah well so also I'm
doing things in like the six to eight
rep range so it's not like developing
big muscles you know it's not like max
like two reps where you're lifting some
huge weights that you're doing at six or
eight times so um you're not really
developing big muscles as you drove all
my strong muscles
I don't know cool I don't know it seems
to be working pretty well thanks I will
see I need a few more months to write
and then just know no decision yet about
what the next thing is well it's just I
just I don't really have the bandwidth
for a next big thing because there's a
movie coming out in the in the fall I'll
be doing all kinds of crazy media around
it I'll be
supporting the book coming out and in
some ways I'm like when does the book
come out probably it probably with the
movie hmm I think everything's kind of
cut is there a release day for the movie
yet September October I think it'll be
in festivals in September and then in
theatres in October right but um that's
the theory but um it's funny that I
think it's called free solo which is
cool it was gonna be called solo which
is even cooler but they're freaking
coming out with a Star Wars movie at the
same time that's called solo that's
right and so then everyone's like oh no
hello is a better name but it's like
it's hard to compete with Han Solo you
know yeah what are the chances of that
that's I know is unfortunate but free
solo is not a terrible name you know
it's it's close so when you're not when
you're not like actively you know
pursuing your prep for a particular
expedition or adventure
like what's a day what's a day in the
life it's going yeah I mean yeah going
climbing and it keep it typing working I
have a bunch of different writing things
going on you know just like little I
don't know some Italian book once a
little essay about something and right
you know just just like life yeah but um
yeah and then normally I do a lot more
adventure he like Hardy you know go for
a mountain bike rides or trail runs or
like fun things yeah more like big
scrambles like so long up up easy routes
but uh but right now because I'm trying
to do this systematic training I've
really cut back on that kind of stuff so
that I recover more so that I can train
harder and and I'm seeing good results
of that but at some point I'm sure I'll
start you know going on biking more
again or something where do you uh where
do you see yourself in ten years or do
you even think about that like do you do
you forecast yourself or think I I think
about it I mean in ten years I wouldn't
be surprised to have a family or
something I have some kids or a kid I
don't know we'll see but uh but
hopefully I'm doing the exact same stuff
I mean hopefully I'm climbing and trying
to get better at climbing you know doing
at least a cool expedition every year or
something and I don't know we'll see
what do you learn from from hanging out
with guys like Conrad from you know I
think that's what I've learned from
hanging out with Conrad is I think that
Conrad is actually a really good vision
of what I would like my life to be in 10
or 15 years he's in person I mean yeah
he has such a good balance cuz he has a
really good healthy family life he's got
a nice situation in Montana where he
lives
but then he still goes on big adventures
but he's been working with the North
Face for 30 years and he's still very
passionate about that and he really
contributes to the brand and it's I
don't know I mean his whole lifestyle I
think is pretty well balanced and and
he's happy with it you know and that's
the important thing
I mean you have mentors like him that
you like run stuff by or how does it how
does that work
or you just rely on your instincts I
mean yeah I mean I just spent six weeks
in a tent with Conrad so so yeah I guess
I ran stuff by I'm a bit but no Connor
and Jimmy both always been very generous
with their with their time and thoughts
and it's definitely helpful that if I
ever have some kind of weird opportunity
I can just call people like them and ask
I wouldn't say any of them are
specifically you know a mentor but I
mean or like I was just saying with
Jonathan Siegrist is my trainer I
wouldn't necessarily call him a trainer
but I mean it's very helpful to have a
friend who's one of the best of the
world and something who you can just who
will just come by the house and help you
with it yeah or was someone like Conrad
just to you you could just look to his
example yeah I was inspiration yeah you
want to model your life yeah I mean
there's several climbers like him
actually Tommy Caldwell is a really good
example of somebody that I would be
happy to model my life around his and
part of buying a house in Vegas last
year was actually looking at people like
Tommy and seeing that part of the reason
that he's financially secure and able to
climb full-time and enjoy his life with
his family is because he's been smart
about you know paying off a property and
having a rental and things like that
like just that he doesn't have to worry
about you know becoming an unemployed
climber yeah yeah but yeah but I don't I
mean I don't worry about that with you I
don't know I mean you know you're not
going to go out and like buy a bunch of
Porsches and stuff yeah I've got the
Porsche behind oh yeah yeah yeah I mean
yeah I'll never be frivolous like that
but but I mean that's a you know all my
sponsors could draw me I could have one
big health problem or something you know
I can get cancer or something like I
don't know I mean you never know what
life is gonna give you well as we close
it down maybe I think it would be good
to like just leave people with what's up
nothing like closing on cancer oh my god
listen madness to you
your your appreciation for the reality
of death you know it's like you live in
the moment in certain respects and and
understanding that you know all we have
is today and how are we going to make
the most of what we have in this moment
right and you're climbing is sort of an
expression of that it really it
punctuated s' the the preciousness of
life by living on that edge in a certain
way I mean when you say it it sounds
very eloquent but I would never be able
to say them that way I don't feel like I
don't know I just love going climbing
yeah but I mean yeah that sounds
beautiful I'm like I wish I did that
yeah you know well for somebody who's
listening who who you know perhaps has
an instinct to go on an adventure but
feels feels trapped or feels like
disempowered you know what kind of
message do you want to convey to that
person oh that's interesting so I mean
this isn't quite a clean wrap-up but um
but so interestingly I'm supposed to
give a TED talk this year mm-hmm at like
the conference in April and they were
like the big Ted
yeah well tastic yeah so I've sort of
written an outline for it and I've like
worked through some ideas and some teams
and which is I'll do basically tomorrow
the end of the month which is tomorrow
and so I'm like oh no but um I think
that what I've been kind of struggling
with or working on is to make the
climbing more applicable to the labors
to any average person or the lesson yeah
and I think that one of the lessons is
or I don't know one of the ideas is like
what is the thing that is worth putting
the work in for you or what is the thing
that's most important to you like in my
case I'm talking about I'll cap in my
preparation for free soloing I'll cap
and and to me I'll cap was the thing
that was worth the work but basically
like what is the thing that's worth it
to you and then what is the work that
you need to put into that you know and
I'm still fleshing out the ideas but
with I'll cap you know to me the big
moments we're sort of identifying that
this is something that is important
enough to my life that I'm willing to do
the work and then the moment where I'd
realised that I had done all the work
that I needed to do which is sort of a
different way of looking at I'm now
ready to do this you know instead of
looking I was like I'm ready to climb El
Cap it's actually more of I have done
the work that I
and therefore you know being able to do
it like naturally follows but um I don't
notice I mean I think that people should
just think about what is the thing that
they want to do and then you know what
what are the steps to do that like what
is the work involved in like I don't I
don't know it's very much a work in
progress no I like that but I mean you
know baked into that is is is an
appreciation for the hard work and the
level to which you know you completely
devoted yourself to this pursuit not
just I'll cap I like you know just
climbing in general in a culture in
which it's all about hacks and shortcuts
right
yeah that's don't drive me crazy yeah
stand it you know I can't stand it if
you really want value out of your life
experience like stop yeah it's about the
process okay I know I know that yeah
because when you're 70 and you look back
on El Cap you're probably not gonna it's
it's the memory of being on the peak
probably pales in comparison to thinking
about all those days of preparation that
you know that's the meaning of it for
you yeah well I mean the memory of being
on the peak is 30 I was still very
excited about it but it is true that in
years and years doesn't mean like
because of it because that's many years
working out of years thinking about it
and yeah no I mean for sure for sure I
mean the idea of you know like what's
the life hack to mastery and you're like
oh the hole by definition mastery takes
years and years you know it's like you
don't you know just like life hack it or
whatever that that stuff it really
annoys me because you know if there was
an easy way to do it then everybody
would do it like you know I mean if it
was easy then it wouldn't be hard yeah
but that's I mean some things just
require time and work and effort and you
just well mastery certainly does
proficiency not necessarily and it seems
like we've we've prioritized you know
adequacy over over like the appreciation
for truly you know what it takes to be a
master of something yeah I mean that's
another one of the ideas that I've been
thinking about a lot with regards to
potential TED talk or something the idea
of mastery and like because that Y is
free solo climbing so important to me
and you know the pursuit of master is a
big part of that like feeling like
you're good at what it is a it is a
manifestation and Express
you know yeah well so what is that thing
you want to master and how much work you
have to put into it right and forget
about trying to take the short route I
know that yeah the yeah 5 minute workout
you're like nobody gets fit in five
minutes
well speaking of mastery you are on your
way to USC tonight to do an event with
Michael Gervais have you met Michael yet
no no I'm pretty excited about the past
I respect him tremendously he's one of
my favorite people and he has his own
podcast finding it does it finding
mastery so he's all a man so he'd show
me the mastery and he's gonna ask you
questions or he's gonna I mean he knows
how to get right
like deep I'm excited about that and
he's very gifted at that and he's a
beautiful guy so that's a cool event for
you I'm excited yeah please say hi don't
fall out I will all right well thank you
so much for doing this well I appreciate
you warming me up for Michael yeah well
yeah we're warmed up and not not talked
but uh no it's good we'll get the best
out of you know I'm psyched so cool man
thanks so much for doing this
if people want to check you out you're
pretty easy to find Alex Honnold on
instagram Honnold foundation org right
yeah yeah contribute write donate come
on yeah yeah yep come on I'm gonna make
you say it please support the foundation
come on get over it it's fine you know
people for recurring donation of
Confirmation utterly anywhere and
anything else coming up no you're
speaking anywhere else like all over but
it's just not really I don't know it's
just like I don't even yeah I mean the
TED talk that'll be pretty pop right I
would be a southwest southwest actually
in March the American Alpine clubs do an
annual dinner in February that I'm gonna
be receiving award uh which for once I
was like oh I get to receive an award
instead of having to speak yeah cuz I've
done a lot of those nonprofit fundraiser
type things where you show up and give
the keynote till I try to draw people to
give to their charity right I was like
all for once I don't have to give the
keynote I just have to go but you given
it you have to give an acceptance speech
no no my acceptance speech is gonna be
like thank you very much and I'm gonna
sit like
what are you doing it South by Southwest
I talk with Jimmy actually oh cool but
no and then and actually I think they're
gonna be maybe premiering the dawn wall
movie which is about Tommy Caldwell
climbing a big moon on El Cap which I'm
pretty excited about seeing that too
cool has nothing to do with me I don't
think but it's gonna be an amazing movie
yeah right on man anyway yeah thanks
thanks for talking to me come back
anytime next if you ever need a place to
park your van he'd come yet next time he
grab a lot right nice and flat excellent
now thank you so much Alex they're
appreciative peace plants
[Music]